oh some maverick christian what a name
well done maverick christian is asked
the question uh why did practically
every expert get it wrong
on the russian invasion of ukraine
yeah and um not that i'd call myself an
expert but me too and i and i think it's
that question we addressed at the
beginning was that
um
we're kind of
thinking in terms of putin being a
rational actor and he and he is getting
he was getting everything he wanted
by saber-rattling and by by sort of
throttling
ukraine and getting all of that sort of
western attention which he wants he
wants to be reminded that russia was a
great power and a big player in the
world and all of that um
and it seems unthinkable that he would
want to
launch full-out all-out war
um
it still seems unthinkable like like
constantine said it's like you know you
almost wake up it's like a dream that's
mad um
that said
uh there were enough
voices amongst the sort of intelligence
community and so on who'd seen
various briefings and
i listened retrospectively actually
earlier this week i listened back to a
a podcast american um
intelligence community podcast
which had three or four commentators on
there and they all differed i mean they
all say oh no i don't think he's going
to invade because he's getting what he
wants that argument that i gave
and this predated the invasion
um and two of them said he wasn't going
to invade and two of them said he was
so there were voices that were saying
you know the intelligence is such that
you know this is not a drill
so there were voices there that were
saying that um but as i said i think the
rest of the world just assumed that you
know he was effectively
oh like if you actually look at putin's
history former head of the kgb you look
at
you know the case of alexander
litvinyenko you look at the poisons in
salisbury
this isn't a man who values human life
very highly
particularly if it's if it means that he
can eliminate them in order to get what
he wants but again this is i'm sorry to
you know say this with with you there
constantine but this is kind of also
um
an element of the russian psyche 100 you
know i i don't want people to be under
any doubt about what you're saying yeah
it's a hundred percent true i mean
you've got to understand this is a
country that killed 20 million of its
own citizens only 70 years ago or 80
years ago whenever it was and you go to
it you go to i mean things always
surprises me in a way is you go to any
of the
um red armies cemeteries but like
there's three in berlin right for the
battle of berlin in 45.
um
the biggest one in treptor park which is
is spectacular sort of monuments and
also gigantic but they're mass graves
like they're mass graves of 5 000 people
each in each of these mass graves right
so the idea of the individual
and they're not repatriated i mean the
way the americans repatriate their dead
from war as a matter of
routine um
russians don't do that right not only do
they not do that they put them into mass
graves so that there are no names right
we don't know who they are which to a
western mind with all of its
individualism and all of that is kind of
completely anathema it's going wow
that's that's
that's punchy you know
that's just the way it works it's the
way it works in 45 it's the way it works
now and that comes direct from the
soviet lens doesn't it
where the individual is
um
the long hard winter yeah i think it's
it you know man is
the individual is kind of expendable and
there are there are greater um goals to
be had and we we get them by
moving together and if the individual
falls off falls off the side then so be
it it's it's that a classic kind of
you know um communitarian
mentality
that the community is everything the
individuals nothing there's another
piece to it as well which is russia is a
massive country and because of that
logistically it was very difficult to
govern and what you therefore needed is
very strong central leadership to
prevent the regions from becoming you
know mini tardems in which the the local
uh uppity king
would do whatever he wanted
and because of that
this is the anecdote i always use to
explain it to try and explain this to
people is uh one of the
huge names in russian history is of
course ivan the terrible
uh he's not called ivan the terrible in
russian
it's not an inaccurate translation this
is a man who killed his own son in a fit
of rage who is a kid tortured animals
who did all sorts of atrocious things
in russia textbook psychopath textbook
psychopath in russian he's called ivan
the fearsome
and revered
yeah stalin has a 50 stalin has a higher
approval rating in russia today than joe
biden has in america or boris johnson
has in this country
that's the mentality and nobody in the
west can understand this because
you can't you can't if you if you
operate under the western moral
framework it's impossible to understand
people who would bury 5000 soldiers who
secured victory in the deadliest war in
the history of humanity
in the mass grave
you can't imagine that yeah
and
a way out that's what i've been arguing
yeah
um
and that probably means i think you know
in an ideal world in an ideal world
they carry on the negotiations which i
think have been rather kind of cynically
led particularly on the russian side so
far that's a ruse to
to buy time reorganize whatever it is
um but anyway at the moment those
negotiations in an ideal world you might
see ukraine being able to fight them
effectively to stand still
or make the costs so great that
putin is ready to make some sort of deal
and i think the best they could probably
achieve
from the ukrainian perspective is
is a return to status quarantine
right so you can have
donates gloucester you can have crimea
but ukraine is allowed to exist now
whether it can exist
with an independent sovereign government
is quite open question but that's what
it should demand
right
um
i think anything else is kind of
you know requiring it to be in a sphere
of influence
pandering to russian paranoia is is is a
hollow hollow victory
so for the ukraine so um
that's an ideal scenario i think that's
about as good as it's going to get
[Music]
um
the other side of the spectrum the
realistic side of the spectrum is i
think the destruction of ukraine
and occupation of ukraine which is going
to be bloody
um
and ukraine's democratic ambitions its
ambitions to join the west
western world in general are going to be
put back by decades
[Music]
so it's
it's
very dark we're in a very dark place at
the moment
and this is why i say this is this is
cold war ii
um we can't afford i don't think the
west to to
whatever happens in ukraine
when it's over go back to some pretend
normal
because that would not be acceptable and
it'll be a betrayal
of all of those brave ukrainians who
have fought like they have
with that ambition
of fighting for their
sovereignty and their freedom
and to decide their own future
if we then
carry on business as usual
vandal deutsche handle
there's a betrayal of them and that
shouldn't happen so you know we do need
to carry on that fight
do you think the west i mean we've all
been surprised in the last week by the
resolve of the west but do you think
if ukraine is overrun
you know russia annexes the eastern and
central part or installs a public
government
um
do you think the west has the appetite
to maintain these sanctions in
perpetuity
i i hope so honestly i hope so
um
and as i say i don't i don't think we
can
in all conscience go back to business as
usual and sort of normalization because
you you'd have you'd have an effect you
know regime like lukashenko
in belarus in ukraine i think that's
probably the most likely outcome
which is horrible to say
and to me that is that is a tragedy
for ukraine
and it's something that we
should
carry on you know carry the carry the
torch effectively for
the freedom of ukraine and certainly
bolster our defenses on that eastern
frontier you know poland has to make
um you know
realize that it's a it's a frontier
country now
um which i i said that last week and
prior to the invasion
it already already has felt that way
with the with belarus and the with the
uh the manufactured migrant crisis of a
few months ago
um
but baltic states poland you know those
all those nato members on the east and
eastern
fringe of europe
we have to make sure that that is an
inviolable line
but no further no step further
but that means putting nato troops
there absolutely
absolutely isn't that going to be seen
as an antagonistic gesture yeah i think
we're past that now
i think we're way closer
[Music]